the first four weeks is called aptitude
it's basically a series of walking over
the hills with a pack that gets larger
and larger with a distance that gets
further and further you know you do
exactly what you're told when you're
told how you're told and you just walk
the hills you know I had toenails
missing I had skin off the back you know
I had blisters on my feet I had a
dislodged retina I had all sorts wrong
with my body but I ended up four weeks
thank you let's start at the beginning
can you talk about what your Early
Childhood was like yeah cool right Early
Childhood then for me consisted of being
born in London where I was adopted this
couple turned up from Southampton he
just lost his job and so he lost his car
as well so they took me home they took
me back to Southampton in a motorbike
and sidecar so that was the first ever
trip out of London was motorbike a
sidecar where I began life in
Southampton uh on edges of accounts for
the steak called Airfield and then as I
grew up my early memories of them really
were him he was a really violent man he
used to drink a lot I remember the smell
of alcohol and obviously I didn't know
it was alcohol when I was little but I
can remember him you know drunken used
to beat the absolute daylight to hurt me
like you know I mean and I was only
small and he was like he was a big man
he was an 18 Stone 19 Stone lump I was I
wasn't a well-behaved kid I can't blame
it all on what was going on at home but
I you know I just I did tension span of
a goldfish like you know what I mean I
never wanted to be in the classroom I
always wanted to be outside I was always
staring out the window always
daydreaming and I got a job as a skiing
instructor down at this place called
casual Activity Center so I was in there
I was working in the workshops mending
skis I was teaching skiing now I thought
I was going to get at the end of this
two years I thought there's no way they
won't take me on because I'm a great
skiing instructor aren't you that I mean
and I'm I'm doing the job here I'm doing
it well well at the end of the day there
was a guy there he'd been I think he'd
been a captain or something in the Navy
and he run the place he was the boss and
he called me into his office and he says
uh he says Pharrell he says your end of
end of your yts is coming up he said
it's been great Avenue and I thought
here he goes here comes the golden egg
like you're like me Bangor and tell me
tell me how much you're going to pay me
and all that no no no he goes I can't
take you on he says you need teaching
qualifications here and you ain't got
none he literally said to me have you
ever thought about going in the army and
I said I thought I looked up I said well
yeah I said I have so literally he
arranged some transport and I went
straight to the careers office from
being with him like you know what I mean
and it was like it was it was straight
down there there was a big old sergeant
in there when he was at Grenadier guard
or something barking away like you know
I'm in and I'm like all right we'll see
where this goes when they came around
with the Sheep to say what you could do
I thought you know helicopter by a
little do me and he says uh infantry
I'm like all right anything else no no
infantry mate that's it inventory so I'm
like I'm pretty much good to go now I
didn't know a lot about the Army in
those days other than what I've seen in
the cadets but I thought look this is my
chance to get away from from everything
you know they're going to take me away I
was going to be training in a place
called Lichfield it was going to be
miles away so so long as I passed all
these tests they gave me I was laughing
I was off and that's basically what
happened I passed me tests and off I
went are you excited by it yeah yeah of
course I was I'm like that no I I just
I'm I'm always no matter what I do I'm
chomping at it like do you know I mean
I'm like wow and I love new things you
know I mean I love new stuff new
challenges and all that sort of thing
you learn all sorts of cool stuff new
stuff you're out there you're shooting
guns you're running around you're on
assault courses it's it's all good it's
all good there was nothing bad about it
do you know what I mean you're eating in
the field you're learning how to cook
you're staying under the stars all that
sort of stuff loved it so
I've got best improve recruit but it was
only it was only about it was about six
months ago somebody said to me that
means I was a complete one when I turned
up and they managed to get me over the
line so it shattered me a little bit
that that is true apparently yeah yeah
it's true someone told me I was all
proud about that for years and then
someone told me right anyway so
but like with all these things you've
had a great time there so you sort of
like reach the top of the training
establishment and then you're like boom
off you go to your Battalion and you're
down the bottom of the ladder again you
know and I got to the Battalion when
everybody had just done a tour of
Northern Ireland so I'm the only Crow
I'm the crow without a meddling I mean
everybody else has got a medal and I'm
like no so I found the first the first
six or seven months of being in
mortality I found it quite hard and I
know you've got to cut your teeth but it
could be in those days it could be quite
tough and there was a little bit of sort
of like bordering bullion if they've
done you know they threat you like you
did nowadays they'd be out with like you
know but in those days you've probably
got a little bit of a character building
they called it in them days you know I
mean bullying they call it nowadays but
character building them I then ended up
with Amalgamated so I was a royal
Hampshire at the time and we Amalgamated
to the princess of wales's raw regiment
now I've done P company which is the
parachute regiments uh tests and again
they have they have come they have
Commando power not Commando Paris
artillery powers and all that sort of
stuff but we did it because we were part
of five Airborne Brigade so I had to do
p company the Brigade Commander said he
wanted an Airborne platoon in every
Battalion that was in the in the Brigade
so we got paid extra money so it just
made sense that I'd do it so so I did it
it was another challenge it was it was a
great challenge at the end of it I
thought well I might as well if I put
the effort in here I might as well see
if I can transfer to the parachute
regiment no no no he wasn't having that
nobody was having that in our place I
put my paperwork in the go for for SAS
selection which I hadn't really thought
about at all up until that stage when
you got to the SAS you revert whatever
rank you are you revert back to Trooper
when you get to the SAS so that's you
done you're a trooper you keep what they
call a shadow rank so you can still get
paid the same as you would be worth but
you you basically revert back as far as
your job's concerned to a trooper so to
me it made sense and look having seen
what they did having had a little bit of
experience watching them in places like
Kenya and Northern Ireland and actually
coming across them a few times these
guys seriously knew what they were doing
like you know I mean you look at them
and it's like wow
and the the selection process for the
SAS is like notoriously different so the
selection process with SAS yes it is it
is notoriously
honking it's just it's a disgusting
process right but here's the key to it
right is the key so I always say young
Lads ask someone who's passed and not
someone who's failed because if you ask
someone who's failed you'll get a lot
harder pictures than someone who's
passed all right now I'm not going to
tell you it's easy because it wasn't
easy but I'm not going to tell you it's
impossible either because when I left my
Battalion there was a sweet potato
saying I wouldn't last a week all right
so people had heard all these stories
from other people I think it's down to
the individual selection is there to
break you they don't want you they don't
want it they don't want nothing to do
with you you are a volunteer on
selection that's a very important thing
for people to realize you don't you get
these people and I've heard it in the
pub myself
like I'm looking for him they picked him
no they didn't you're a liar you know
man you're full of it because they
didn't pick him at all what happened was
he had to put his paperwork in like
everybody else if he wanted to go on
selection because they don't go
headhunting they literally you you
volunteer and actually if you if you
look on an sas guy's medals it will say
SAS volunteering brackets all right it
will say he's a volunteer massively
important press gang soldiers do not
perform like volunteers ever all right
that's that's a fact so
um you volunteered to go on selection
the first four weeks is called aptitude
as far as the the SAS is concerned we
call it the tree other Hills all right
is the hills face it's basically a
series of walking over the hills with a
pack that gets larger and larger with a
distance it gets further and further you
know you do exactly what you're told
when you're told how you're told and you
just walk the hills and that's it and
it's designed in four weeks you know if
you really don't want to be there you
probably will have will have handed
yourself in by now do you know what I
mean because you know if you don't want
to be there you won't stay because it is
one of those things it will break you'll
break you eventually uh also it will
find that if you're robust enough you
know I had toenails missing I had skin
off the back you know I had blisters on
my feet I'd have dislodged retina I had
all sorts wrong with my body but I ended
up four weeks you know I had plenty of
excuse to say I'll say what I've had
enough do you know what I mean but I
wanted to be there at the end of that
four weeks they probably don't even know
your name
they're certainly not interested right
they want they want they want a group of
soldiers that they can take to the
jungle and they'll train properly so the
jungle phase once you get to there
that's where the real soldiering Starts
Now the Jungle the jungle's twice as
honking as the hills because it's like
the hills but it's covered in trees and
it rains you know at least twice a day
torrential rain which gets you
completely soaking through uh it's hot
it's humid you sweat so you're wet for
the time you get in there after the time
you come out you're wear all right it's
absolutely minion you live as if you
were tactical the whole time so you
never ever go to the toilet on your own
your weapon your weapon goes absolutely
everywhere with you you've got this
finger but you've got to perform the
whole time you're in there on the canopy
for about six to eight weeks I can't
remember exactly how long but you're
you're in there everything they want you
to do they teach you first so they will
show you absolutely everything then
you'll practice it and then you'll do an
exercise at the end
so it's not it's not impossible but it
is extremely hard like I say with all
these other things going on you've got
insects you've got everyone wants your
dead in the jungle everything including
your instructors all right nobody wants
you alive okay so it's it again if
you're not gonna make it mentally you're
gonna get found out in the jungle you're
going to get found out there's no chance
you're going to get to the end of eight
weeks living like that without unless
you really want to be there
and I actually
I enjoyed it I enjoyed the jungle now we
are Gucci guns now we were doing Gucci
things do you know what I mean and I'm
thinking now this is good this is proper
now this is like this is what I joined
up for you know we're doing all this
sort of stuff we're getting proper
assets from ads you know I mean if you
need a helicopter you'll get a
helicopter now all that sort of stuff
you know I mean before in the normal arm
you need a helicopter or Bedford will
turn up and you'll pretend there's a
helicopter you know what I mean no no
yeah you get the real deal like you know
so everything everything is is good in
the hood you're there you're learning
and I love learning so I'm like a sponge
do I mean I'm taking this stuff in yeah
you have your bad days yeah I had a
couple of times and I thought well can I
really take this but overall because of
the amount of stuff that I was learning
I absolutely loved it and I think if you
speak to people who've been on selection
who've passed selection they will tell
you how much they enjoyed it even though
it was insanely difficult
and then you get badged and it's like
you get given you better you know Co
comes around it literally was we were
sat in a line and it's not it's no big
ceremony or nothing like that the CEO
comes in says how lucky you were all the
past that's how rubbish you are until
you've done something proper throws your
bury at you and that's it you're like oh
cheers for that and I remember literally
I got to my Squadron and we were on um
we were on counterterrorism and so you
go well you've done your counter
terrorism training you do some training
with a squadron you get broken into your
team's red team blue team as it was at
the time you've got your Range Rovers
and all this and it's like great it's
like wow this is real and I've got a
pager I've got given a pager and I'm
like wow I've got a page first time we
laugh for some responsibility like I
mean little pager and you get told you
know if it goes off you've got to get
back to camp and all this sort of stuff
and I'll stuck it in my pocket and it up
everywhere every only child up took it
everywhere I'm walking around
Sainsbury's it was a Saturday no it was
a Sunday that was a Saturday
and I've got it on silent but you get it
started vibrating I mean pocket oh
that's nice oh when did you get off oh
oh no no one hey hey it's me pager so
I'm in Sainsbury's how many packages
going off I'm like oh oh I wanted to go
and save the world like boom I'm down
the road I'm up I'm running I'll go past
the ship pass the workshop I'm at the
road I'm sprinting I am proper moving
now so I'm running down the corridor and
I'll get there and I'll do like this
comedy stop in front of the start
Major's desk I'm here sir he goes well
I'm really glad about that he said the
Vic and he's the temple
they're thicker I'm not really everyone
else is coming this afternoon I don't
know
human but there you go that's still like
it's a humbling thing isn't it yeah I
mean bottom of the party didn't you
you've just passed selection you joined
your squadron bottom of the ball
so I was in the SS for about five years
but I had a great time
I had a great time in the regiment a
really good time so yeah did some did
some did some cool stuff some of the
stuff obviously you know you're not
allowed to talk about I just you know
probably the biggest thing that's public
that that's known about that I did was
the operation where we saved the Royal
Irish Lads from the West Side Boys in
Sierra Leone so that was
that was a that was a that was a good
operation for me and then pretty much
I got out I left I left I left the
regiment I was a little bit of a I was a
bit I was a bit of a tear away I was a
little bit too handy with you sometimes
um and I fell out I fell out of a few
people and ended up my PVR that I bought
my way out so at that particular time
when I got out for the first couple for
the first couple of months I actually
run out of money I couldn't get a job
anyway and I went to the job center and
I remember going in there and you could
you know you get a crisis loan didn't
you you get this thing called a crisis
land and I went in there to get me
crisis line I'm like yeah 78 pound or
something it was and I sat in there and
I got interviewed by this girl she must
have been about 18 years old now you
have to take an interview you have to
take a job interview or you can't get
your dough that's the score right so she
says well I'll take your information
don't put in the computer she says I'm
struggling to find you something and
then she goes Bing oh I found you a job
interview to go to she says it'll be
next week yeah what's happening lollipop
man in Margate
lollipop money market I'm like are you
real are you for real yes yes I'm for
real your appointment time will be such
and such and you can collect your check
on the way out like do you know what I
mean I'm not going to be going I've got
me 78 quid and I'm going to have to go
to this interview like Anyway luckily
about a day later someone offered me
some stuff and said look if I could get
myself to Afghanistan I could have a job
out there and I literally went out to
Afghanistan almost straight away so yeah
I was fairly lucky you ended up in the
private circuit yes basically
I mean it can be anybody can be on the
circuit if you know the right person if
you've got the right contact you know
I've seen all sorts of people out on
some of these jobs especially you know
an Afghan and Iraq are both going at the
same time they couldn't fill enough
seats and basically what it will consist
of is use the escort in jobs training
jobs anything that the the military
can't cover haven't seen like for
instance I did a job for the European
Commission now it was a great job it was
a full diplomatic privileges job we
looked after the European Commission
because I didn't have a dedicated CP
team and no one one country was prepared
to go right we'll give you hours so they
farmed it out to a private company now
the the the stuff that I enjoyed was the
like the Afghan and the Iraq and there
was a little bit an element of danger in
there and it you know I I got into loads
of scrapes it was
it was a poor second to the Army
it was certainly a poor second to
Special Forces however on the plus side
of things you could earn anywhere up to
120 200k a year
it was it was it was a great experience
you know I did Afghanistan I did Iraq I
did Gaza I did all over West Africa I
did the anti-piracy stuff so there was
always something to do always something
that you could get involved with so you
know varying degrees of danger varying
degrees of pay even you know some jobs
paid extremely well some weren't some
might have all the danger and no pay
so I might have all the paying no danger
it was it was a proper Lottery like do
you know what I mean but it was fun I
had a great time doing it you know it
was something that it was a calculated
risk every time I went I have turned
jobs down if I thought they were too
insanely dangerous I have turned them
down I'm not one of these to just go out
the gate you know willy-nilly on
anything I will have a little look at it
and I think it's not not applicable to
me or within my skill sets I won't do it
simple as you know no matter what animal
says to me but if I do think I can do it
you know an element of risk to you
all day in the office to me you know so
that's that's the way I Work It
you mentioned the piracy circuit so the
only piracy stuff was Gulf of Aiden a
bit of a problem with pirates in Somalia
and I'm going to be really honest here
right I'm going to be honest if I was a
Somalian if I was a Somali goat earner
and and a Somali fisherman and you
ruined my Coastline with you it in the
water I'll start taking ships and all
right so I think a lot of people are
sort like oh scumbags well scumbags they
might be but they're scumbags who
ultimately in the early days you know
their fishing Waters were destroyed
nothing was given to them in
compensation they had no way of making a
living so they started to pinch a few
ships that's a fair one in my book I'm
telling you all right so
at the time when I first went down there
there was a thing called the
international internationally recognized
Transit Corridor right and it was it
went along the top of the Gulf of Aden
and you've got a warship escort through
there but either end of that once you
broke away you were fair game and I
remember
oh I'm a first ever job so my first ever
job on anti-piracy absolute disaster
um I'll get asked to go down there down
to pick a pick a ship up I get told that
when I get to the port there's going to
be a load of Defense stores I'm going to
get loads of barbed wire I'll get there
nothing absolutely nothing so I phone
the office in London where's me barb
wire uh right it's going to be there
someone's going to get so I managed to
get get down to the agent again he goes
I've got your wire it gives me a thing
of gardening fine right I'm like what am
I going to do with that I found the
office up and I said to them
what am I going to do with gardening
time and literally the guy on the other
end of the phone a bloke called will
we're not going to say his full name
local will win nobody said it was going
to be easy
all right and that was it that was all
the early days and it was like so I knew
I got on the ship
um I got on the ship and went to defend
this ship with nothing no guns no
nothing uh in the knowing that the
Pirates had guns
and they had you know range they had
they had little boats to come and attack
you and all that sort of stuff so it'd
be turned into like you go and grab the
boat and straight away
and go and write his store whatever you
could get you know you'd make you'd make
spikes I'd tip oil all over the decks
and make them slippery anything you
could it was like an 18th
and you'd be half like defending this
before you got there and it really
was potluck you know you could have no
guns but you could have flares I
remember we took crossbows on one uh so
you could you could pretty much take
what you could lay your hands on on a in
this country so not you can even take
knives with you really do you want me to
be in the Cookhouse with the chef seeing
if he could borrow something like
something you could stick someone with
they got on now drill wise you would say
to the crew
if it all kicks off you go down into the
into the Citadel into the bottom of the
ship and the two of three rivers will
stay at the top to deal with it now the
early tactics area with these ships
would be simple as I knew that you know
a Somali farmer in a boat going like
that with an AK-47 that isn't likely to
hit much right so my theory was if I
could build something that looked like I
was going to fight him if I could get
him to start shooting at me brilliant
awesome because he ain't gonna hit me
all right so I'll let him spray all his
bullets off and when he's run out of
bullets he'll go anyway okay and that
literally was our plan see if you can
get him to run out of bullets and Fuel
and turn around okay because other than
that he was in it right if they got on
you could be quite heavily in it as well
first attack then first attack
bobbing along and I had a guy with me
who was a complete drunk
and he just he wasn't up for it he
didn't feel well and he just drank the
whole time we were there so I ended up
doing a lot more time on the bridge than
what I should have done the captain of
the ship he was Russian complete drunk
didn't want to go through pirate water
the crew weren't up for it he was
absolutely scared anyway we get we
joined the battleships he's all happy
he's up at the front he's driving the
ship right we're getting to the other
end he disappears anyway we've gone for
about we've read it up we'll turn him
right we're going up towards Egypt we
come out of here and um I see these two
little specks behind us I'm not could be
could be could be
keeps an eye on the radar
one of the one of the ship's crew sees
it uh uh what what is this Mr Phil what
is this I'm like don't worry about it
don't worry about it nothing nothing
they're getting closer so I say to the
I'll say to the first officer I said
change direction slightly so he changed
his Direction sure enough boom these
things tuck in and come with us I'm like
that's Pirates definitely Pirates I'm
trying to go I'll go right you might
want to get a few people downstairs get
them out of the way get them locked up
but don't worry about it it's probably
not Pirates by these days I might as
well just hit a panic button they're all
over the place these people so they've
gone downstairs the only person who
stayed with me was the boson and he was
quite a fit all that and he I knew he'd
be probably quite up for a row as well
so we're up there we've got a couple of
bags of nuts and bolts we've got three
flares
and that's it that's it bust so like I
said we were going to do I've got a
wooden gun right that I've cut out of a
piece of cardboard as the Pirates come
up the side let them have a little look
yeah sure enough up they start shooting
they ain't in nothing they ain't getting
nothing near me dude I mean it's all
flying well and you know when
something's got you get that but when it
starts it's all it's coming over the top
with Glenn miles away so all these
bullets go all over the place they do
one pass they get close enough for me to
think I can have a go with the flare so
I'm right okay when he comes in I'll see
him and dead towards the side of the
ship
it's his love and I've taken the
parachute out of it so so it's not going
to stop it's just going to keep going
um and it's all like skews past him now
he's laughing at me he's like oh you got
he's laughing I was his great big grin
from the ship like this from his little
boat he's grinning at me I'm like all
right okay he's got me rumbled now ready
so
I'll have another one when he comes a
bit closer
it misses him by about that now I'm
grinning I'm thinking I could possibly
get you with the last one well the last
one goes disastrously sort of into the
sea I'm like honestly last one so as
he's getting up to the side of the ship
with Lobby nuts and bolts out and we
don't care you don't care now he's
getting on as far as he's concerned and
he's trying to get this ladder on now
we've got no nuts and bolts left and no
no flares we're like oh what we're going
to do so I'm not thinking what can I do
I'll go running into the bridge to see
if I can find anything I can lob at this
Geezer anything at all don't care what
it is anything
looks around the captain's got a fridge
in there a little fridge was Cokes in it
right little like it's all like portable
fridge type thing and it's got Cokes in
it but it looks quite heavy and I'm like
that look inside this coach all right so
empty this out rip it out
go running down to the bridge Wing look
over the edge and think right he's
trying to hook on this guy so the boat's
going like this in the wake of our ship
and he's trying to hook on I think right
I've got probably one chance to do this
so I'll look over the edge of the ship
and I think right what I'm going to do
is I'll have to get his attention first
because I want him to see me I want him
to know that I'm doing this right so
I'll yell over all right listen as he
looks up I throw this fridge as hard as
I ever can at him and it whistles by it
must have missed his head by by
millimeters and it goes smashing into
where he's trying to join the ship to
ours on his on this rope thing it severs
that and they go bobbing away backwards
and luckily it was enough he saw that he
must have thought this guy's a Nutter so
he's had enough and he and he turned
around and went
I got to the stage with the circuit
stuff and obviously as we spoke about
you know I've been taking I've been
taken twice I've been taken once in
Afghanistan you know only for a short
period of time but also been taken in
toga
I I in my own mind was running my luck
out here all right I was thinking myself
what can I do well I wrote a book called
Born Fearless big plug all right I knew
when I wrote it it was going to start
closing a few doors down but I was a bit
older and I thought right it doesn't
matter so much now because I want to try
and transition away and do something
else but when I first thought I took my
foot off the gas
I couldn't
I couldn't find any work whatsoever the
book had done okay but I wasn't going to
retire on the book and
I had a bit of money saved up in the
bank then and I was drinking and I was
proper drinking and I'm one of these
people if I if I do anything I'd do it
to the absolute Max all right so I was
drinking far too much
I'll start getting a bit of trouble I
had a bit of a domestic at home and I
put a window through but I don't put
Windows through with I'll put a window
through with a bed I mean I'll throw a
bed through my front window
um
there was a neighbor
and I called him a load of and I I must
have said to him I don't want to kill
you or whatever like you know I mean
because next minute loads of police have
turned up they've dragged me out my
house I've had to roll around with them
I've gone down to the police station
they come into me cell and the first
they tried to charge me who attempted
murder for this
insane even the duty solicitor this is
insane anyway she said you're going to
go up in front of the beak on Monday
they're going to try and remind you in
custody and try and sort this out so
they've lowered it to attempt to gbh I
felt proper though it was like and look
this is this is again some mental health
stuff kicking in here
people have always said to me that you
are crazy if you talk to yourself well
I'd say to you now that you're crazy if
you don't because I looked in the mirror
in in Marcel in Winchester and the guy I
saw was a complete all right I knew you
know although I wasn't guilty of
attempted this attempted that and
attempted the other in fact probably at
worst a bit of a bit of noise had been
made like do you know what I mean and
I've broken my own property well so what
so you know that aside I'd still manage
to put myself in a position where now I
was you know I don't be Liberty taken so
you know I I had messed up in my own
mind I had a proper work with myself you
know
uh it took me a while to sort it out it
took me about four or five about six
weeks in Winchester before finally my
they let me out on license I went on a
tag uh stayed at my brother's house
eventually all the sort of like layers
and restrictions got let off I managed
to get get it allowed out till midnight
because I told them I thought I'd work
to do in the city and all that sort of
stuff I lied like a cheap Japanese watch
you end up in the office you know what I
mean and then I might offered me a job
in Albania so off to Albania I went tag
came off completely and I said look you
just need to be there on the day you've
got to go to court went to court it all
got dropped the judge actually had to go
out and I got done with I think a
section five you know disorder charge
you know causing someone of normal
firmness of mine to feel for his stroke
her safety it's nothing you can get done
with that if you spat at someone in the
street or call them a name you know it
was nothing so it all got it all got
washed down but ultimately it damaged
what what my credibility was work wise
in the security business you can't you
know my license has been revoked by the
time I was on the tag I wasn't going to
get them back straight away so now I was
pushed in the corner when I had no work
so I literally had nothing I phoned
around all the normal places where I've
got work nothing nothing sorry Phil no
can't do it now no nothing I'm in the
brown sticky stuff now and I was you
know I mean I've got nowhere to go so I
sort of like thought to myself right
what I'll do is I'll go on Facebook and
see if anyone's got it and I've got on
Facebook and my cousin got hold of me
I said look Phil he said I've got a
building site and um he was running a
building site in Sutton in London he
said look if you come over there he says
you can you can out you can labor he
says it at night if you want to stay
there if you can get hold of a caravan
or something if you can stay there he
says you can you can be the security and
in the evenings I used to take like 15
20 quid if I had it and I was to go and
places like the Ivy and all that and
I'll take a copy of my book and if I
heard any of these like any of these
types talking about TV and oh by the way
my name is Phil yeah and I was to just
introduce myself in other people's
conversations and before you knew it
I've managed to Black my way on the Sky
News is like all this stuff was going on
terrorism why hasn't I managed to Black
my way in and every five minutes the
first one went particularly well
um and every five minutes I'm on Sky
News and eventually they gave me they
gave me the documentary
um
which was what was the documentary big
fields War which went down really well
one thing I have learned in this
industry nobody is just going to hand it
to you no one's just going to give it to
you and if you if you and I remember my
adopted mother I might not have gone
with her but she did always used to say
to me if you want a job do it do it
yourself like you know and I think
that's the way for me and you know even
when I spoke to bear I said you know I
can't rely on anybody in this industry
you know whether they're a friend or not
I've got to go out and I've got to do my
own thing and that's exactly what I'm
doing and I will never give up with what
I do because you know I do believe in
myself if nobody else does do you have
any um like advice you'd like to give to
anyone who yeah my advice to anybody is
look as far as we know life is not a
rehearsal all right we're not here we're
not here teeing ourselves up for for
another go at it later on you you will
get out of life what you put in
just never give up you're going to be in
a situation many a time where where
you're at the bottom of the Heap okay
but when you're at the bottom of the
Heap if you're still drawing breath into
your lungs well there's a chance you can
get to the top of that Heap again and I
I would I would say to anybody just
never ever give up on your dreams and
your hopes and you'll get there
eventually
it might be the long way around but you
will get there eventually and even even
even if you didn't well at least you
gave it your shot
[Music]
I looked up and I could see two guys
with a PKM belt fed
um washing machine gun
and they were hammering down on the lads
my rifle only shoots 1500 meters
so I had to I call it lobbing I lobbed
the bullet in